[Música]
tudo bom gente boa tarde
é antes da gente começar a palestra eu
queria fazer uma pergunta e eu queria
que vocês fossem sinceros comigo
quantas pessoas nessa sala tem acesso a
um laboratório científico de alto
rendimento
toda vez que eu faço essa pergunta eu
tenho sempre a mesma resposta
a maioria das pessoas não têm acesso a
laboratórios que sá de alto rendimento
mas hoje a gente vai mudar esse
resultado agora estão preparados
então quantos de vocês têm acesso a um
local como esse em casa
parabéns a todos vocês têm acesso a
laboratórios científicos de alto
rendimento
só porque porque laboratórios nada mais
são do que espaços de experimentação e
qual o lugar da sua casa se exige mais
do que a cozinha onde para preparar a
comida
você tem que manipular os alimentos
provar essa aqui sou eu
há dez anos atrás no laboratório de um
restaurante onde eu trabalhava
essa aqui também sou eu esse ano no
laboratório de tecnologia da
universidade de nova iorque gente
laboratórios são espaços que todos nós
freqüentamos muito mais do que a gente
imagina
eu faço parte de um grupo de pessoas que
acredita que a ciência e tecnologia foi
incríveis e são sim revolucionários mas
elas são mundanas
mas eu tenho consciência que a maioria
das pessoas não pensa dessa maneira
quando a gente pensa em produção de
ciência e tecnologia dois clichês do
senso comum
vem pra nossa cabeça o gênio e o doido e
essas duas imagens fazem com que a gente
acredite que a ciência tecnologia estão
muito distantes do nosso dia a dia
só que isso não é verdade
se querem ver quantos de vocês têm
filhos ou já tiveram que cuidar de
alguma criança em algum momento
então vocês já se depararam com uma
situação muito parecida com essa que é o
seguinte você seguiu o protocolo você
instalou portão a gente não sabe como
ele conseguiu subir e aí agora situação
problema como é que se vai resolver aí
que você faz um mês e se desespera né
depois se pensa faz um rascunho os
metais às vezes se adota alguma coisa e
aí você chega a uma conclusão abandonar
seu senso estético na sala que a criança
não vai fugir pra cozinha
só que aí um dia mesmo você tendo
resolvido esse problema
você teve que sair de casa e aqui que
teve que fazer
você teve sistematizar e compartilhar
esse conhecimento que o problema
realmente ficar resolvido sem depender
de você olha vocês aí fazendo ciência e
tecnologia
mas como é que isso tem a ver com
ciência e tecnologia
gente pra mim ciência é criação de
conhecimento e tecnologia é uma
ferramenta que a gente utiliza para
resolver o problema
a gente precisa urgentemente
desmistificar e oferecer acesso ao
ensino de ciência e tecnologia
principalmente no brasil
a automação já é uma realidade
como a gente pode ver aqui em outras
palestras que isso traz todas as tarefas
mecânicas todas as fórmulas prontas
não sendo resolvidas pelas máquinas e
isso está trazendo uma revolução que a
gente não está conseguindo prever como
vai ser o mundo do trabalho
oitenta e cinco por cento dos trabalhos
de 2030 ainda não existe e para
sobreviver nesse mundo a gente precisa
preparar as nossas crianças ea gente
precisa trabalhar nelas três habilidades
e criatividade resolução de problema e
senso crítico é o brasil falando do
cenário de ciência e tecnologia que vive
uma situação totalmente paradoxal a
gente não investe em pesquisa e
desenvolvimento
mas ao mesmo tempo nós estamos entre os
países mais criativos do planeta
como isso é possível porque a inovação a
inovação raiz mesmo de verdade ela
acontece onde é necessária no brasil a
gente precisa muito que a gente tem
muito programa para resolver o
brasileiro
ele domina uma habilidade que é
essencial na produção de tecnologia e de
ciência sabe qual é essa habilidade
a gambiarra
a gambiarra é a arte do civismo é a arte
de você enxergar as coisas não pelo que
elas são mas pelo que elas poderiam ser
só que aí no mundo formal acadêmica do
mercado de trabalho o que a gente faz
com essa habilidade a gente rejeita por
que não é bonito porque não atende ao
senso estético pasteurizado que falaram
pra gente quer o aceitável e aí um monte
de idéias legal que tem potencial
revolucionário vai pro cemitério ea
gente coloca num pedestal a idéia de que
para você produzir
a tecnologia você precisa ser raro
quando na verdade baixa está vivo
esse cara aqui arquiteto no tomo comprar
uma impressora 3d
ele queria utilizar com os alunos na
comunidade estava perto do laboratório
dele mas ele percebeu que era muito caro
em que o impacto dele é muito reduzido
porque não ia poder oferecer aquilo de
uma maneira acessível para os alunos o
que ele fez ele abriu impressora
entendeu como ela funcionava e aí ele
sacou que é onde ele vivia tinha um
monte de comunidades que sobreviviam de
descarte eletrônico e aí ele criou uma
impressora 3d um discaço eletrônico que
está 100 dólares
a ema uma designer holandesa muito
interessada em texturas e tecidos criou
uma embalagem feita de cogumelo
o primeiro protótipo disso ela fez com
que ela chamava de oeste leve e aí todo
mundo fica achando que era um lugar
incrível que era chamado de cozinha da
casa dela
a universidade do ceará descobriu que o
couro da tilápia tinha uma concentração
de colágeno incrível e que poderia ser
utilizado como bandagem para tratamentos
isso revolucionou a ala de queimados do
hospital esse tratamento hoje em dia é
adotado em diversas comunidades
internacionais
toda grande invenção começou como uma
gambiarra
se alguém batesse na porta de vocês hoje
e falar assim aposta nisso
muito provavelmente vocês não apostariam
nesse protótipos esquisitas não gostei
de fio é esse aqui
se esse visualizador com black jeans
black tempo em volta né
esses são os primeiros protótipos
funcionais de duas invenções que
revolucionaram o século 21
o primeiro é o óculos rift óculos rift é
considerado o melhor visualizador de
tecnologia
tridimensional atualmente há uns anos
atrás ele foi comprado pelo facebook por
alguns bilhões de dólares segundo o
arduino placa única que possui
possibilita trabalhar com software livre
que revolucionou a maneira como a gente
ensina eletrônica programação interativa
se você tem um espaço maker um espaço de
experimentação e você trabalha alguma
coisa relacionada de eletrônica você com
certeza tem uma placa dessas nas
universidades na sua casa na sua escola
mas olha como é que eles começaram eles
eram feios
eles eram toscos mas eles funcionavam
gente chegar até aqui é muita coisa
chegar até aqui significa que você já
dominou mais de 60% do método científico
você identificou analisou o lugar onde
você mora
você identificou hipóteses para um
provável acidente com um problema você
identificou hipóteses você protótipo e
você testou seu experimento pra vocês
finalizar o método científico você só
precisa da análise da conclusão se isso
aqui é tão importante porque a gente não
começa então a dar o devido valor que
tem
primeiro a gente tem que começar
trazendo para nossa casa
esse aqui é o meu irmão que é 28 anos
mais novo do que eu ea gente se encontra
semanalmente quando ele vem a minha casa
militar ea gente faz experiências
só essa foto que foi tirada quando a
gente estava fazendo a experiência da
fuga seleta né
hoje em dia é islaine né isso aqui era
terceira receita porque o ácido bórico
que a lente de contato que você coloca
para dar liga não estava funcionando
aliás essa é a melhor receita tá é cola
ácido bórico para dar liga um pouco de
creme de barbear e e uma pitadinha de
hidratante
depois que a gente normaliza a
experimentação em casa a gente tem que
trazer o lugar onde a gente realmente
consegue mudar a cultura de um país e
mudar o modelo mental que dentro da
escola
a gente precisa trazer a experimentação
investigativa para dentro das escolas
vamos nutre o nosso cientista criativo
aquele que nasce com a gente quando a
criança
os olhos reparou como é que a criança
olha para o mundo vem pra cima
pressionando atenção nas árvores nos
prédios
tocando né a criança ela enxerga o mundo
pelo toque
inicialmente vamos nutre esse cientista
criativo para que quando ele cresça ele
possa virar um adulto e um cientista
cidadão e como cientista cidadão ele
possa fazer aquilo que é o que nós seres
humanos fazemos de melhor as invenções
que transformam a humanidade
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]